dans l'actualité ce soir un titre
principal disparition dans son sommeil
de soeur emmanuelle qui aurait eu 100
ans le mois prochain sa vitalité son
irrévérence et son combat pour les
pauvres en avait fait l'une des figures
préférées des français
les hommages sont innombrables une messe
solennelle aura lieu à notre dame de
paris
elle nous évoquerons la femme de foi la
femme d'action et la femme de média avec
nos invités jacques duquesne bernard
kouchner et michel drucker bonsoir et à
tout à l'heure
l' enquête interne du fmi sur dominique
strauss kahn devrait s'achever à la fin
du mois déstabilisation ou rigueur à
l'américaine le calendrier de ces
révélations suscitent en tout cas des
interrogations une procédure
administrative est ouverte sur des
violences policières à montfermeil lors
d'une interpellation l'homme a été
frappé une vidéo met en cause des
fonctionnaires aux états unis john
mccain évoque pour la première fois
l'éventualité de sa propre défaite face
à barack obama
le facteur racial peut-il jouer au
dernier moment
nous irons dans le mississippi ancien
bastion de la ségrégation
enfin le gouvernement présente son plan
numérique pour tous une carte d'identité
électronique sécurisée sera notamment
lancé pour prouver son identité sur
internet
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous elle était
d'abord une voix et un visage
écoutez soeur emmanuelle par elle même
si mauvais
moi j'ai goûté tous les fruits de la vie
peu importe laboral de bompas pas mais
moi j'ai pris le christ comme modèle il
n'empêche que pas il m'a appris à aimer
il m'a appris le dos dubai pris la joie
la joie
le don des paroles prononcées il ya
vingt ans la nuit dernière madeleine 5 1
alias serait manuel s'est donc éteinte
dans le sud de la france
on va s'y arrêter longuement direction
d'abord callian dans le var c'est là bas
dans la maison de retraite de la
congrégation qu'elle s'était retiré ces
dernières années elle est morte de
vieillesse
2 fatigue sans souffrir dans son sommeil
sur place nathalie jourdan raymond chape
l'art depuis ce matin seuls les
pensionnaires et leurs familles peuvent
entrer serait manuel vivait dans cette
maison de retraite depuis 15 ans elle
avait rejoint ici les soeurs de la
congrégation de notre dame de sion elle
croisait aussi d'autres pensionnaires à
la messe vous accueillez toujours à
baconnes s'ouvrir à moi je forme des
brevets a qu'à lyon on avait pris
l'habitude de la croiser dans les rues
du village
quand elle allait voter ce tout près
d'ici à l'école là je m'avançais vers
elle me prenait par le bras comme si je
devais la soutenir au bout de quelques
pages avait l'impression que c'était
elle qui m'importait c'était assez
extraordinaire c'était quand même
quelqu'un de très humain
quelqu'un haut niveau je trouve que la
vie d'une spiritualité
c'est sûr que ça me fait chier vraiment
des arbres affaiblis
la religieuse ne quittait plus sa
chambre depuis trois ans mais elle
continuait de recevoir de nombreuses
visites
les gens qui venaient la voir il venait
maginfique genre donnait toujours un
morceau de gâteau pour y porter parce
qu'elle était gorman serait manuel
aimait la vie
mais elle attendait la mort pleine
d'espérance je me suis éminemment
réjouit pour pour soeur emmanuelle parce
que vous le savez elles vous l'avez
suffisamment dit pour elle c'est le jour
formidable c'est le jour qu'elle
attendait le jour de son face à face
avec ce seigneur auquel il s'était
consacré il ya maintenant fou 80 ans
pour ses obsèques la religieuse avait
donné des consignes strictes
seuls ses proches doivent assister à la
cérémonie serait manuel sera enterré
mercredi à callian auprès de ses soeurs
les français ont découvert et admiré
assez tard sept religieux atypique qui
avait dédié son existence aux plus
pauvres seraient manuel a connu
plusieurs vies un parcours de rupture
laetitia legendre
elle voulait mourir en egypte auprès de
ces chiffonniers
mais c'est dans sa maison de retraite
que soeur emmanuelle s'est endormi pour
son dernier sommeil serait manuel un
sourire malicieux
une voix qui résonne des coups de gueule
aussi
presque un siècle au service des plus
démunis
ce qui compterait année mais primaire
ci-contre et s'est commise sans parfum
de richesse incroyable et que les autres
n'ont rien ça c'est pas possible il ya
là quelque chose en soi même qui
appellent à la révolte elle né à
bruxelles en 1908 d'un père français et
d'une mère belge à l'âge de 6 ans la
petite madeleine 5 1 va vivre une
épreuve à jamais marquante la noyade de
son père je crois que cette petite fille
qui allait bientôt à voir si genre
puisse être un moment je vois cette
petite fille là a tout à coup compris
quelque chose qui est bien utile sont
l'âge mais pourtant à quel point le
bonheur peut tout à coup s'engloutir
dans les eaux tout à coup c'est fini
pour toujours pour toujours cette soif
d'absolu ne va plus la quitter
issu de la bonne société belge amoureuse
de belles toilettes
elle trouve pourtant les hommes son
grand intérêt pour elle à 22 ans elle
entre dans la congrégation de notre dame
de sion et devient soeur emmanuelle
après 40 ans d'enseignement à l'étranger
à l'âge où l'on part à la retraite
elle réalise enfin son rêve partagé
l'avis des chiffonniers du caire
parmi les tas d'ordures les rats et les
cochons
elle se bat contre la drogue l'alcool
elle va jusqu'à écrire personnellement
au pape pour lui expliquer toute
l'importance de distribuer la pilule en
egypte madre est possible de croire que
dieu veut que ces femmes et des cloches
du les dix mois la solution c'est une
solution intelligente de contraception
en 1981 elle crée son association a
smile et s'envole vers l'europe pour
lever des fonds
la chiconnière devient médiatique une
religieuse révoltés qui ne mâche pas ses
mots devant la société confirmation que
je viens d'apprendre que il y a ici en
europe du lait des céréales des pommes
de terre du beurre qu'est ce que je sais
moi encore et que cela ne sert à rien
mais ce rythme annuel épingle aussi le
confort de l'église s'interroge sur le
mariage des prêtres
confie ses doutes et cet amour éprouvée
pour un professeur alors qu'elle
enseigne j'étais complètement bouleversé
que sur moi-même je ne me comprenaient
plus comment j'avais fait un voeu
d'appartenir seulement chénière et voilà
que je sentais que mon coeur brûler pour
celui qui n'était pas le seigneur
justement parce qu'il était très bien ce
professeur
alors que son association se développe
la retraite un mot qu'elle déteste la
rattrape à 85 ans elle doit rentrer en
france
arrive le temps de la reconnaissance en
2002 elle reçoit la légion d'honneur
devient l'île des personnalités
préférées des français tutoie les
humbles comme les puissants écrit des
livres rend visite aux détenus est infér
palier jaune en parlant leur langage
y'a pas de look chic à duke toi nous
avons il a du lourd
félicie continue la mort elle
l'attendait sans la crainte d' déjà
étonné d'une vie aussi longue et pleine
la mort comme celle qu'a su aimer ce
sont les retrouvailles c'est le vote aux
vagues du fian chez effet fiancée de
l'enfant avec son père
delaby avec l'abri et avec tous les
hommes il suffit d'aimer 10 et elle est
toute sa vie la petite soeur des
chiffonniers à aimer avec abnégation
on évoquera dans un instant la
personnalité hors du commun de soeur
emmanuelle
mais elle est d'abord connu de tous pour
l'action qu'elle a menées dans les
bidonvilles des chiffonniers du caire
on l'a évoqué il ya un instant elle leur
a consacré 20 ans de sa vie à l'âge où
beaucoup souhaitent se reposer philippe
rochoux les femmes et les enfants des
chiffonniers du caire c'était la vraie
famille de soeur emmanuelle
cent mille personnes vivent des tonnes
d'ordures charriées par cette mégapole
de 17 millions d'habitants seraient
manuel aura passé plus de vingt ans par
mieux
partageant jour et nuit le fardeau de
leur vie quotidienne je suis pour moi je
devais supporter ces saluer d'abord
faire la faire comprendre que j'étais
leur cher qu'en soeur emmanuelle arrive
au caire en 1980 elle est émue par le
sort de ces familles chrétiennes qui
n'ont pas l'eau et l'électricité les
enfants travaillent à la décharge dès
l'âge de 10 ans et ne vont pas à l'école
elle va récolter des fonds pour les
aider à bâtir des écoles et des maisons
seraient manuel se souvient du jour où
elle a fait venir pour la première fois
l'électricité dans le bidonville la nuit
toutacoo l'électricité a éclaté dans le
bide aux riches était tactique pour les
c'était dur les ténèbres
en quelques années elle transforme la
vie des habitants du bidonville
la plupart des enfants vont à l'école et
pour elle ils sont sauvés aujourd'hui
l'association serait manuel rayonne sur
les bidonvilles du caire les habitants
lui sont reconnaissants elle a construit
des hôpitaux
elle nous a donné tout ce dont on avait
besoin oui les pauvres qui n'avait rien
elle a fait construire des maisons
elle les a tellement servi si les
chrétiens les musulmans
l'électricité l'eau les égouts grâce à
elle elle a servi tout le monde sans
discrimination serait manuel a quitté
les bidonvilles du caire en 93 alors
qu'elle avait 85 ans un déchirement pour
elle et pour les habitants bonsoir
jacques duquesne bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes un journaliste un
écrivain
bien connu vous venez de publier avec
annabelle cayrol ce livre j'ai 100 ans
et je voudrais vous dire chez plon un
livre d'entretiens avec soeur emmanuelle
où elle se raconte que retenez-vous
d'elle d'abord cette espèce de joie qui
émanait des leurs fins cette espèce de
le bonheur si vous voulez quand on lui
fait ce livre juste avant l'été et alors
elle nous dirons tous les gens quand ils
vous voient cet âge là où parle de la
mort mais moi la mort ça sera le bonheur
j'ai retrouvé l'homme que j'aime lettre
que j'aime mon grand amour je vais le
retrouver elle redoute est pas la mort
clients mais alors et les peurs de
l'agonie a pour seul a eu de la chance
j'étais content pour elle ce matin quand
j'ai entendu qu'ils avaient était morte
dans son sommeil pas dit quand je dis je
lavialle goni ça me fait peur parce que
je n'aime pas la souffrance
les gens qui font de la religion nos
régions de la souffrance du sacrifice
moi je ne serai jamais fait religieux si
le catholicisme avait une région de la
souffrance et du sacrifice parce que
c'est une religion de la joie et ça
c'est vrai à laver ça vraiment nous
profondément donc qu'elle ait peur de
l'agonie et quand elle parle et fait du
cimetière où repose et ses soeurs
religieuses à disait je vais là je me
dis bon car elle serait ce pas là le
mois des eaux 1
il restera les dents et s'est même pas
les miennes ouais alors qu'elle
cultivait à plaisir alors c'était une
femme de foi vous êtes vous aussi ré
homme de foi paddock pas dans le même
registre mais en même temps là souvent
pris l'église à rebrousse poil
on l'a entendu sur la pilule c'était le
cas aussi sur le mariage des prêtres ça
lui a jamais valu deux condamnations
d'ennui ben non apparemment puisque bon
on peut raconter l'histoire de la
contraception puisque elle a écrit au
pape jean paul ii elle a fait porter la
led pour être sûr ça se perde pas dans
les couloirs du vatican quelque part
prend un fait porter la lettre par
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien qu'il
a remis au pape une lettre à laquelle il
est écouté les filles ici au bidonville
à 11 ans 12 ans 1 sont pratiquement
vendu un monsieur
elles font un gos par an et ce gosse et
un sur deux meurt dans l'est
les années qui suivent donc qu'on
distribue chez moi les médecins
distribuer des pilules contraceptives et
impartiaux réponse alors j'ai dit pâle
était pas content peut-être le pape est
ce qui fait non si gris ne répondait pas
c'est que et fermer les yeux
il pouvait pas répondre et il voulait
pas répondre ne l inde côté n'ai pas
envie de répondre oui parce que ça sera
répandu à travers toute la terre
aussitôt qu'il prenait à contre-pied le
papa poule 6 avec human éviter c'est les
papilles même pas se contredire
ils vous disent une chose différente des
anecdotes parfois mais je toujours en
disant qu'ils disent tous la même chose
depuis le début donc finalement l
arrivée affirmé vous restez avec nous
jacques duquesne serait manuel était une
femme de foi une femme d'action aussi on
l'a vu et son oeuvre humanitaire
concerne aujourd'hui plus de 70 mille
enfants dans une dizaine de pays alors
question at elle des héritiers la
réponse en images avec karine comazzi
manille philippines face aux gratte-ciel
du quartier d'affaires des montagnes
d'immondices
c'est là que les 5000 enfants du
bidonville trouve de quoi vivre et puis
les ordures qu'ils peuvent revendre ce
qu'ils peuvent utiliser pour
confectionner les objets récupère même
ou partie de leur nourriture là dedans
et c'est affreux puisque live battre
pour y bâtir des empires kouassi
julia ces jeunes diplômés en
développement durable son premier emploi
à la choisit de l'exercer pour 700 euros
par mois au service des plus pauvres
dans l'association fondée par cette
autre femme de 75 ans son aîné la
réussite c'est pas qu'elle est dans les
nuages avaient l'habitude à
l'imagination l exil et de quelle
manière
près de 300 personnes des jeunes femmes
surtout aide à scolariser 70 mille
enfants dans les pays les plus pauvres
du monde comme le fait juliette à
manille
on arrive dans la maison de mêlée face
et le prévient qu'il n'y a pas
d'électricité chez elle nous montre où
vivent les petits écoliers parrainé par
l'association à semaine c'est le seul
moyen pour la famille de s'en sortir
c'est le gars m'a t-on un boulot dans un
bureau dans une fraction toute la vie de
la famille va changer on ne peut plus
avec des associations
ça peut pas avec des bénévoles et qui
ont du coeur il faut avoir des gens
compétents qui savent ce dont ils
parlent
et quels sont les moyens de réponse
juliette est compétente mais face à la
drogue et la prostitution elle connaît
les limites de son action
or m nl et déjà une personne c'est
énorme moi j'ai la vie que je voulais et
je travaille que je voulais je me sens
en harmonie avec les valeurs avec ce que
je veux être bon tour bernard kouchner
vous êtes en direct avec nous du
ministère des affaires étrangères une
femme d'action engagé dans l'humanitaire
comme vous vous étiez proche y at il un
souvenir en particulier qui est associé
à elle pour vous oui il ya un souvenir
c'est quand j'ai dansé le tango avec
elle pour un anniversaire sans doute ses
90 ans
et puis beaucoup d'autres souvenirs
vous avez parlé de manille elle a aussi
essayé de créer réussi à créer des
écoles au soudan avec ces réfugiés du
sud qui arrivait dans des cloaques
autour de khartoum
et puis ses colères et est un souvenir
personnel parce que elle arrivait
toujours à nous enroulé autour de son
petit doigt et elle avait aussi cette
formidable capacité de mettre ensemble
les humanitaires et les politiques pour
de bonnes raisons pour de mauvaises
raisons aussi je n'en sais rien mais les
mettre ensemble ce qui était une gageure
elle avait c'était une femme magnifique
elle avait les yeux d'un bleu de la mer
du nord et elle racontait sa jeunesse
avec des étoiles dedans avec ce petit
chat lequel avait coquettement c'est
difficile d'être coquette dans un camps
ce fondé sur des ordures avec des des
sacs et avec des caisses de bois et bien
elle avait l'air élégante et elle avait
une allure formidable ça c est ce que ce
souvenir de force
est ce que vous diriez que d'une
certaine manière c'était une femme
politique c'était tout à fait une
politique
elle voulait changer les choses mais
elle n'avait pas la religion du tout
comment dirais-je de l'abnégation du
salut elle était capable de vous
expliquer pourquoi il fallait sauver un
homme même si on ne pouvait pas les
sauver tous
qu'il fallait s'attacher à quelqu'un et
tâcher de le rendre heureux pour
osciller bonheur qu'on en concevait soi
même pour le plaisir qu'on avait de le
faire même si on n'avait pas de solution
pour tous
alors cette solution pour tous elle la
cherche est évidemment elle l avait
trouvé dans dieu merci bernard kouchner
et puis on ne peut pas évoquer soeur
emmanuelle sans s'arrêter sur sa malice
sa liberté de ton son excentricité
parfois qui en avait fait une
personnalité très présente dans les
médias une personnalité très populaire
aussi avant de retrouver avant de vous
retrouver michel drucker aussi
quelques-unes de ses apparitions qui
prêtait à sourire et souvent aussi à
réfléchir perrine monnaie est ce que
vous êtes heureuse d'être là je ne sais
pas encore guéri d'après les questions
trop souvent sont des questions
tellement superficiel que tant demandé
jeudi pourquoi suis je venu
et toc et puis j'ai moi les messieurs un
homme c'est petit c'est petit et leur
dire c'est le père de l'homme qui
justement est devenu dur c'est le père
de l'homme qui se ferme qui ne sait pas
aimer c'est le coeur d'un homme qui a
les autres pour lui chassez la vraie
hors du mou niveau je suis ton père
voici mauvaise moi j'ai goûté tous les
fruits de la vie peu importe laboral de
bompas pas mais moi j'ai pris le christ
comme modèle il n'empêche que pas il m'a
appris à aimer
il m'a appris le dos ibai pris la joie à
la suite par la ram à la glace et la mer
littérale en fait l'arabe d'égypte je
sais pas si vous pouvez vous comprendre
que tu as échoué lâche rien
moody's a une fille vous avez qu à l aps
amusée mme baddou
parce que la peluche pas cette année
excusez-moi juillet alors il ya des
similitudes à wigan illégal rap 2001
actuellement je sais très bien que je ce
que je fais moi pour la misère du monde
c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
jusqu'à ma mort je verserai cette goutte
alors je désire par est oui et pour 10
n'oubliez pas quand je bois je vous dis
lui aviez de mon association
et si vous aidez bien certaine manière
vous avez et millas à sa chaussure est
belle elle est sauvée pour 70 de
marketing tempère michel drucker on vous
a vu vous étiez un ami de soeur
emmanuelle vous étiez vous connaissez
bien
vous étiez très proche elle aimait ça
les médias elle aimait la télévision
mansat mais elle était devenue une pro
des médias comme la vespière d'ailleurs
elle a découvert les médias sur le tard
mais elle avait un réseau avec quelques
copains comme c'est avec patrick pas en
avant il y avait fuit gildas qui avait
consacré un reportage qui l'avait fait
connaître à l'époque elle était encore
avec les chiffonniers du caire
elle avait l'oeil elle avait la voix
révèle agwai et surtout elle avait plus
de 40 ans d'enseignement dernière m elle
savait capter les vous laisse avec
capter un auditoire
elle était très maligne et quand ils
voulaient quelque chose d'abord étudier
tout le monde sauf le pape un jour des
marchés jean pierre raffarin qui est à
matignon prémunissent elle ça serait
l'unique oh mais tu gagnes jean pierre
laborde et ben je sais pas me chercher
ta feuille de paye tu donnes combien aux
pauvres elle tapait à la porte de
boutros boutros ghali de monsieur chirac
de bernard kouchner comme ça elle
obtenait ce qu'elle voulait est-ce
qu'elle met la notoriété
alors oui elle aimait ça mais ce méfier
elle avait elle avait 10 et j'ai peur de
céder à la traction de mon ego mais elle
adorait ça mais attention elle nous
engueuler beaucoup s'il n'y a pas
d'autres mots pour moi chaque fois parce
que elle disait vous à la télé vous
reste en surface
il faut
vers le haut 1 d'abord les nouveaux
riches souvent au pas de goût et il faut
que les pauvres et droit au beau et
après 40 ans d'enseignement elle avait
70 ans quand elle dit ma vraie vie
commence
hélas une vie qui a duré quarante ans
elle a eu six lors de l'incroyable
l'anelfa qu'ennemi dîner à la maison
j'étais plus fatigué qu'elle avait déjà
92 ans elle m'a dit tu me fais des mots
les thugs j'ai des frites
vers 11 heures du soir jeudi fall et le
coucher comment ça j'ai pas fait d'y et
c'était maladie
cela fait c'était une nature incroyable
une force physique c'était quelqu'un qui
a vécu dix vicois c'est vous et vous
équipe vous avez réalisé michel l'une
des dernières sans doute la dernière il
a alors jeté là par cet été et puis
alors elle m'a traitée de deux petites
natures
j'avais le dos bloqué dit je peux pas
venir semaines et alors il ya une
console hélène l'accord cam qui la
connaît bien qu avait fait reportage sur
alcatel et la voix c'est sa dernière
interview en voici un petit extrait ou
gérer la totalité dimanche entre 10h et
20h
l'actrice yade radiologue ya trop de
pauvres victimes
je sors mon impuissance prévient qu'une
chose que vous priez pour eux il faut
que l'homme fait des efforts c'est ça le
problème
c'est un problème qui est terrible tout
ce qui se passe qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire justement à ceux qui font
ce monde mais à vis du ahly et des nez à
peu les outre est pas belle ma pas si à
leur propre intérêt mais les autres
aussi un tel intérêt
et c'est qui ce raid passionne à paul a
livré son regard sur la société qu'est
ce que vous savez michel de soeur
emmanuelle dans le privé dans la vie de
tous les jours que nous ne savons pas
tout ce qu'il la connaissait pas
personnellement c'était quelqu'un de
passionné mais c'est quelqu'un qui a eu
je suppose qu'à la fin de sa vie l'image
de son père qui s'est noyé sur la plage
de blankenberge près d'ostende à la
vessie
c'est d'image l'a hanté toute sa vie
elle en parlait pas et puis on en a
parlé et c'est vrai que vous imaginez ce
que c'est qu'une petite fille qui a 6
ans voit son père disparaître dans les
flots ne jamais revenir ça c'est une
image c'est pas être d'accord elle été
emportés par voilà sinon c'était c'était
quelqu'un qui ne se décourage et pas
qu'ils trouvaient que le monde avance ai
pas saisies on entendait laver trop de
pauvres qui n'aimait pas beaucoup les
hommes qui aimait les femmes il était
féministe elle le disait avérée dans
l'interview féministe 1 elle est une
épouse des positions très très engagée
elle adorait les enfants elle n'aimait
pas les hommes elle est trouvée violent
allez trouver sexy et trouvez qu'il
s'était mal conduit avec les femmes avec
les enfants dans toutes les époques ce
n'était pas tout à fait faux et puis
vous avez connu une expérience
particulière avec l michel ah ba vous
allez nous le raconter échelle à kayes
en l'avoir sais pas si lui elle avait 92
ans je suis dans l'hélicoptère c'est une
de mes passions m bia les allées on
s'envoie en l'air
montre moi montre-moi caillan la maison
de retraite ou à la cptaq ya quelques
heures vue d'hélico est bien avec 92 ans
avec les ravis on s'est baladé pendant
un combat de thèmes d'hélicoptère il est
un baptême de l'air première fois
qu'elle survolait voilà voilà où elle
s'est éteinte où auront lieu ces
obstacles demain et elle était folle de
joie elle avait pas peur
elle voulait que ça continue voilà elle
a accepté que la france
c'était une jeune fille avec un regard
bleu carte web le tout à apprendre
d'elle beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
witsel d'ipo aimé et il faut il faut
aimer les ports etc
il avait quelque chose qui me semblait
très intéressant moi c'est qu'elle
disait tu comprends tu donnes un euro à
un mandant un mendiant il reste
mendiants alors ce qu'il faut c'est
faire quelque chose parce qu'ils
observeraient s'en sortent la vie vous
imaginer ce qu'elle dirait ce soir de la
crise financière dans le monde
absolument je l'aurais pas sa langue
dans sa poche et ses conseillers de
s'intéresser beaucoup aux enfants parce
que le disais c'est que les enfants
qu'on pourra changer le monde c'est pas
en donnant un souhait quelqu'un etc
c'est il faut que les enfants et surtout
les filles alors a été heureuse je pas
la plus belle journée de sa vie d'après
ce qu'elle me raconter c'est quand un
lycée de filles qu'elle avait créé
alexandrie avec une autre arrive yeuse
comme ça elle est en uniforme buzz en ce
pays d'à les écolières sont en uniforme
un seul lycée pilar plus tard et se
seront pas faire voilà vous allez va
merci l'humain un nouveau diffusons le
son vivement dimanche voilà demain soir
à 20h45
regardez bien demain l'image de soeur
emmanuelle main dans la main avec l'abbé
pierre c'est une image au lit merci à
vous deux avant de refermer ce chapitre
quelques réactions celle du vatican qui
rend hommage à une grande figure de la
charité chrétienne celle de nicolas
sarkozy elle était notre soeur à tous et
savez nous interpeller on écoute
également le cardinal philippe barbarin
martin hirsch et ségolène royal
je crois que c'est la même chose qu'avec
la vespière c'est à dire c'est l'amour
gagne contre tours voyait l'amour est
plus fort que tout donc ça ça lui vient
de sa froid de son attachement créé ce
sa consécration christelle brûle de cet
amour et vous voyez bien que ça dépasse
les frontières du catholicisme du
christianisme des religions et
finalement ça touche tout le monde elle
a renoncé à une vie favoriser à une vie
plan-plan à une vie facile pour aller
donner d'elle même et puis à engueuler
comme ce doit quoi les gouvernements ce
qui donnait pas assez ceux qui se
bougent mais pas suffisamment oui
c'était mais c'est une révolte positive
une révolte ce sympathique elle se
révoltaient avec eux avec le sourire
elle cherchait pas à culpabiliser elle
les a mais si vous lui donnez 10 vous
pouvez donner 1000 un moment
l'argent est devenu fou et gère
aujourd'hui le monde plus que jamais son
message est d'actualité puisqu'elle
s'est mis au service des plus pauvres
des plus déshérités et sans jamais se
départir de sa joie et de sa gaieté
voilà sachez que france 2 bouleverse ses
programmes pour l'occasion demain soir
donc à 22h40 la chaîne rediffuse
vivement dimanche de michel drucker
consacrée donc à soeur emmanuelle
et puis mercredi la rédaction sera
mobilisé pour l'hommage rendu à la
religieuse lors d'une messe célébrée en
la cathédrale notre dame à paris
éditions spéciales à suivre à partir de
14h autour d'élise lucet les autres
titres de l'actualité et d'abord cette
nouvelle mesure du gouvernement français
après la crise financière françois
fillon annonce une enveloppe de 5
milliards d'euros destiné au financement
des collectivités territoriales région
département et surtout municipalité elle
vise à répondre à l'assèchement du
crédit comme pour les pme il s'agit de
prêts de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations et des banques elles
sachez que la bourse de paris a terminé
en hausse de près de 4% aujourd'hui en
marge de cette crise financière nous
revenons maintenant sur l' enquête
interne du fmi sur dominique strauss
kahn elle devrait s'achever à la fin du
mois et elle suscite je vous le disais
des interrogations déstabilisation ou
rigueur à l'américaine au correspondant
à washington ont rencontré le
journaliste du wall street journal qui a
révélé les faits reportage alain de
chalvron aaron heilman
de l'extérieur rien n'indique que le fmi
est dans la tourmente
pas de télévision pas d'agitation les
employés n'ont rien à dire aussi peu je
n'ai rien à dire je ne connais pas les
détails
le directeur général dominique strauss
kahn est pourtant l'objet d'une enquête
suite à une relation inappropriée comme
on dit joliment ici aux etats-unis avec
une employée du fmi piroska nagy une
affaire révélée par le wall street
journal
si l'on trouve qu'il a obligé cette
employée à avoir une relation sexuelle
alors c'est très sérieux s'il apparaît
que la relation était consensuelle
le conseil d'administration aura une
décision difficile à prendre
il y a un an et demi paul wolkowitch le
président de la banque mondiale la
maison soeur du fmi avait été contraint
à la démission non pas en raison de la
relation qu'il avait avec une
subordonnée
mais parce qu'il lui avait donné une
augmentation anormale
rien de tel à par an aujourd'hui when
she was quand elle a quitté le fmi l'a
t'elle fait de son plein gré ou at elle
été forcée at elle reçu des indemnités
excessives
mon impression est que ce qu'elle a
touché et est dans la norme
correspondant à son rang le cabinet
d'avocats chargés de l'enquète par le
conseil d'administration du fmi pourrait
rendre ses conclusions dans les jours
qui viennent
dominique strauss kahn a en tout cas
présenté ses excuses ce matin et sa
femme anne sinclair l'a déjà absous nous
nous aimons comme au premier jour
écrit-elle dans son blog cette affaire
tombe au pire moment en pleine crise
financière dans laquelle le fonds
monétaire pourrait avoir un rôle
important à jouer
il ne serait de l'intérêt de personne
qu'il se retrouve ainsi déstabiliser il
est à noter cette réaction au
gouvernement d'eric besson
cette affaire est absolument dérisoires
dit il la crise encore l'événement est
symptomatique des têtes sont tombées à
la caisse d'epargne 48 heures à peine
après la révélation d'opérations
spéculatives qui ont coûté 600 millions
d'euros
les dirigeants ont démissionné sans
délai sans indemnité ni parachute doré
fabien shadow frédéric basket
le conseil a accepté la démission de
monsieur charles milhaud président du
directoire la sanction
est tombée hier soir brutale et
définitive à l'issue d'une réunion de
crise pour sceller le sort des trois
principaux dirigeants de la caisse
d'epargne les 17 présidents des caisses
régionales se sont retrouvés pendant six
heures jusque tard dans la soirée le
président charles milhaud plus de 40 ans
de maison quitte le groupe
sans indemnité son numéro de nicolas
mérindol va prendre la direction du
crédit foncier une filiale de l'écureuil
quant au directeur financier julien
carmona il devrait retrouver une autre
fonction au sein de l'entreprise
vendredi dernier quelques heures après
l'annoncé d'une perte de 600 millions
d'euros sur les marchés
nicolas sarkozy en voyage au canada
réclamait qu'à la tête de la banque les
responsabilités soient assumées deux
jours auront suffi pour les
représentants des salariés
cette sanction était indispensable il
était nécessaire d'envoyer un signal
fort à la communauté professionnelle ce
message a été transmis et est de nature
à renouer avec la confiance de capital
confiance étant quelque peu érodé le
projet de fusion de l'écureuil avec les
banques populaires est toujours à
l'ordre du jour les discussions vont se
poursuivre pour donner naissance à la
deuxième banque française
des images maintenant qui provoque le
trouble sur les méthodes de la police
elles ont été tournées lors d'une
intervention à montfermeil en seine
saint denis un homme a été frappé à
plusieurs reprises lors de son
interpellation
une enquête interne est ouverte orolia
guillemin abdel zhiwei montfermeil
il était 22 heures
des renforts de police viennent d'être
appelés cité des bosquets pour venir en
aide à une patrouille cible de jets de
pierre et de mortier de feu d'artifice à
la recherche des fauteurs de troubles
les policiers investissent cet immeuble
pour y interpeller abdullayev 20 ans
suspectés d'avoir participé aux
échauffourées
sur ces images on le voit frappé par des
policiers
j'ai reçu des coups violents dans toute
ma famille des coups des coups des coups
mattrach strasbourg abc de vous défendre
j'ai pressé de me défendre je pouvais
penser impossible quand vous avez
plusieurs policiers qui viennent sur
vous c'est vraiment impossible de se
défendre
les autorités ne mettent pas en cause la
fiabilité de ce document filmée par un
vidéaste qui dit avoir assisté à la
scène par hasard sans plus de précisions
le maire de montfermeil décrit lui un
climat tendu dans la cité j'ouvrais
constitue sa dans la totalité du
contexte de cette soirée où à plusieurs
reprises 7 à coups de cailloux et de
mortiers que les forces de police ont
été attaqués lors de l'interpellation
un policier a d'ailleurs été blessés
tout ça s'est passé dans un climat très
tendu mais encore une fois ce ne saurait
être une excuse pour justifier des actes
s'ils ont été commis qui n'ont pas être
commis par des policiers dans l'exercice
de leurs fonctions la police des polices
a été saisie pour éclaircir les
circonstances de l'interpellation à
l'étranger c'est dans quinze jours
maintenant qu aura lieu l'élection
présidentielle aux états unis distancée
dans les sondages john mccain a évoqué
pour la première fois l'éventualité de
sa propre défaite
j'ai eu une vie merveilleuse je peux
retourner vivre en arizona et
représenter mes administrés au sénat fin
de citation barack obama lui accélère
encore le rythme de sa campagne en
multipliant les réunions dans les étapes
décisives comme ici en floride où il
sera ce soir aux côtés d'hillary clinton
beaucoup aux états unis s'interrogent
pour savoir si le facteur racial peut
jouer dans les derniers jours
nous entamons ce soir une série de
reportages avec une plongée dans le
mississippi bastion de la ségrégation et
du ku klux klan envoyés spéciaux arnaud
boutet olivier robert dans le sud
profond les belles américaines font
partie du décor
philadelphia mississippi les rues sont
calmes
sauf le dimanche où résonne la fièvre
religieuse
ici elle va durer trois heures au même
rythme
l'église est à l'image de la population
les noirs ils sont majoritaires
quasiment tous votre eau obama et ils
attendent le grand jour
avant je n'aurais jamais imaginé que
peut-être un jour on aurait un président
d'origine africaine après tout ce qu'on
a vécu ici car l'histoire se révèle
sanglante en juin 64 le klu klux klan
assassine trois militants antiracistes
de blanc un noir la sphère devient même
un film mississippi burning
le responsable du triple crime n'a été
condamné qu'en 2005 soit quarante ans
après les faits noir et blanc côte à
côte sur le terrain dans les tribunes la
ségrégation dans les stades dans les
écoles appartient à l'histoire
philadelphia tourner une page elle
compte des noirs dans la police tout le
monde se connaît on plaisante
ce n'était pas le cas il y à 35 ans mes
parents avaient tellement peur que si la
police avait été là devant chez eux ils
ne seraient jamais sortis pour
simplement discuter ou présenté avec les
policiers
le mississippi s'est-il totalement
libéré de ses vieux démons
philadelphia ville à majorité noire dans
un état blanc malgré la mixité le vote
raciste n'a peut-être pas disparu je
suis certaine que beaucoup votre sans
écouter ce que disent les candidats
choisiront par rapport à la couleur de
la plaie toujours dur à mon père me l'a
toujours dit c'est comme ça c'est la
couleur de peau sujet sensible
il n'en parle jamais comment avec son
chien rocky le responsable local des
républicains trouve un autre argument
pour contrer obama obama est socialiste
pour moi c'est une question de vivre
si le pays devient socialiste alors tout
est perdu
et s'il est élu fait déprimer son
coiffeur la firme
il n'a rien contre les noirs c'est sa
religion qui m'inquiète
qu'est-ce qu'elle a sa religion c'est un
musulman enfin je crois
vous êtes sûr non non il n'a jamais dit
qu'il ne l'était pas il a dit qu'il
était chrétien
tout le monde peut dire qu'il est
chrétien mais l'être vraiment c'est
autre chose
obama musulmans mauvais chrétien dans le
sud
la parade peut faire mouche et blanc
vote ici en majorité mccain et les noirs
obama et si ce dernier l'emporté bien
cette élection provoquera un véritable
choc dans cet état qui jusqu'à présent
est très conservateur un mot et une
image de politique en france avec cette
photo de famille aujourd'hui au tour de
daniel cohn bendit en vue des
européennes en juin 2009
eva joly josé bové antoine waechter
cécile duflot et les proches de nicolas
hulot était présent un rassemblement de
toutes les sensibilités qui espère donc
ainsi mobiliser les électeurs en juin
prochain image signée bruno girodon le
gouvernement a présenté son plan
numérique pour tous
aujourd'hui eric besson en l'occurrence
a égrainé les mesures en voici les
principales il est question d'un droit
opposable à internet haut débit soit en
2010 une carte d'identité électronique
sécurisée sera lancée où je vais son
élite identité sur internet
et puis également au programme
l'installation de 400 cyber base dans
les écoles primaires d'ici à 2012 il
faut savoir que le taux d'équipement
numérique des ménages est en hausse
régulière
c'est devenu un budget important 170
euros en moyenne par ménage sully à
beaumont romain beauty frédéric capron
l'appartement de la famille du pot c'est
un peu l'index d'un grand magasin
d'électronique consoles de jeux internet
lecteur dvd téléviseurs ordinateurs
imprimantes lecteur mp3 sans oublier
bien sûr téléphone portable pour papa
maman et leur fille
il n'a bien plus le chat qui ne soit pas
encore équipés qu'est ce que je veux
benoît a déjà eu des autres tournent à
un ordinateur un portage ça si si j'en
avais mal face à saintes la route
cette famille n'est pas un cas isolé en
moyenne nous dépensons de 1270 euros par
an pour les nouvelles technologies
la facture monte à 2920 si le foyer
composé d'enfants première dépense et de
loin les abonnements portable ou
internet
viennent ensuite les équipements puis
enfin les dépenses de presse ou de
loisirs au palmarès des équipements
l'écran plat est le plus demandé devant
l'ordinateur puis le portable des achats
de plus en plus réfléchi on s'aperçoit
que les gens aussi spécialise leurs
achats et s'ils veulent faire de
l'internet ils achètent un ordinateur
qui fait de l'internet s'ils veulent
faire du jeu et à celle du conteur qui
fait du jeu mais de moins en moins des
produits qui font tout et ils achètent
plusieurs produits spécialisés chacun
dans leur domaine
85% des français possèdent un téléphone
portable
pour l'instant seul un sur trois ont un
écran plat en équipements de plus en
plus demandés et qui du coup sera sans
doute l'un des produits phares de noël
en bref une image de football en ligue 1
la victoire de l'olympique de marseille
hier soir à valenciennes 3-1 à but pour
marseille signé koné ben arfa et kaboré
marseille qui prend la deuxième place du
classement à seulement un point de lyon
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle le principal titre la
disparition dans son sommeil de soeur
emmanuelle qui aurait eu 100 ans le mois
prochain
ça
vitalité son irrévérence son combat pour
les pauvres en avait fait l'une des
figures préférées des français les
hommages sont innombrables
une messe solennelle aura lieu mercredi
en la cathédrale notre dame à paris
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 cold case affaires
classées à 23h15 ne manquez pas
complément d'enquêté avec benoît
duquesne voitures propres le marché de
dupes point d'interrogation à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 pourrait faire
votre soirée sur france 2
on a dans l'idée que vous savez comment
norris hall est mort quelqu'un faisait
payer à maurice le fait d'être différent
pour dire la vérité il avait toujours
été à part comme garçons en 1984 un
jeune danseur était confronté au manque
de souplesse de ces familles lilly rush
tente d'élucider les circonstances de sa
mort ensuite avec benoît duquesne et si
c'était un marché de dupes si ces
voitures propres verte écolo qui
fleurissent au salon de l'auto n'était
en fait que des attrape-nigauds